welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Joker tends to create quite a
stir and that's largely thanks to a wide
open ended ending it's impossible to
trust anything we see in this film like
as the credits rolled I was in the
audience screaming liar why spoiler
warning if you have not seen Joker yet
though you have had time but Arthur flex
final minutes abruptly incarcerated in a
mental hospital
in the psychiatric ward of a prison is
presented not unlike the final twists of
movies like the usual suspects are Fight
Club in which the protagonist is
suggested to be an unreliable narrator
in the events of the movie we've just
seen are fictitious lies and with in
Arthur's elaborate autobiographical
[ __ ] the most striking moments are
the ones in which Arthur really crosses
a line by taking lives
Arthur appears to murder at least seven
people throughout Joker but with each
kill there are just enough bizarre loose
ends in inexplicable details to make us
question whether Arthur really did
commit each of those murders if we
assume that everything in Joker's
narrative is false how did these murder
scenes in particular if Yuri watch them
closely reveal the mentally ill patient
at the heart of this story is actually a
villain only in his own imagination join
me as I investigate Arthur flex
deceptions and delusions of grandeur in
this episode of total conspiracy ok let
us begin with the first time Arthur
snaps when he gets jumped by the three
Wayne Enterprises Wall Street jerks on
the train and then bang he uses the
revolver given to him by Randall to
shoot the ringleader right in the eye
then bang bang he shoots the second man
in the chest twice the third runs down a
train car then Arthur shoots him once
bang bullet appears to hit him in the
leg the train stops the guy's freaking
out and runs down the platform
Arthur fires again dropping the guy at
the steps and then walks up to him and
shoots him three Bank more bang times
bang now that should raised some red
flags first red flag earlier when
Randall gave him the firearm Arthur
claimed to have little experience around
guns like when posing with the weapon in
his apartment he accidentally fired it
yet here suddenly he's a pretty good
marksman he hits a moving target with a
38 which is not easy to aim for
beginners even at stationary targets but
the bigger red flag Arthur fires eight
shots from a revolver that contains six
rounds he clearly never
reloads to quote my favorite comedy that
means that'll be 1 plus 1 plus 2 plus 1
not 1 plus 2 plus 1 plus 1
now characters firing unlimited rounds
without ever reloading is definitely
something we see in movies and TV shows
all the time
you can argue it's not that serious of a
plot hole but after one puts two plus
one poses one with just one round left
why does the director have Arthur fired
three more shots the last guy at
point-blank range when one shot Alou and
would have stayed true to the logic of
the moment it's as if the director
deliberately went for overkill in order
to make this moment illogical as if it's
a revenge fantasy of an oppressed
mentally ill person who suddenly sees
himself as a sharpshooter in a movie but
if a gun that fired two extra impossible
rounds ain't smoking enough for you look
back at the woman the three victims were
taunting before Arthur intervened notice
the coat her eyes this woman is the same
person that aren't there later sees in
the back of a taxi wearing a clown mask
now it is possible that this woman whom
those men bullied would be in a way
pleased with Arthur for killing them and
maybe be an eager early adopter of his
mob of followers but what kind of
message would this subtle super
miserable wardrobe detail serve if
that's all it meant I would argue that
Arthur seeing the train woman as one of
his first disciples is stronger evidence
of a madman constructing a false
narrative with himself as a hero and
those he saves following him like
members of a cult following their Manson
but before continued thank you to
manscaped for sponsoring this episode
manscaped comm is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene they created the world's
first manscaping kit that makes the
process safe and easy their perfect
package 2.0 kit features the lawnmower
2.0 one approved cordless electric
manscaping trimmer with proprietary skin
safe technology meaning no Nick's no
snags and your bathroom not looking like
Joker's apartment after he was done with
Randall yikes there's a lot of one
listen to that purr like a kitten
eyeballs ain't scared they're ready for
grooming the perfect package 2.0 kit
also comes with several liquid
formulations to round out your
manscaping routine including the crop
preserver anti chafing ball deodorant
and the crop Reviver refreshing spray
also for your balls look if you put
deodorant under your pits
you gotta show some love to your bits
purchasing the perfect package 2.0 kit
gives you your biggest bang for your
buck as a subscriber you'll get 20% off
your order
instantly a new replacement blade every
three months and for a limited time not
one but two free gifts these shed travel
bag and high-performance anti TV
manscaping boxer-briefs
yep they slid right off because thanks
to manscaped I am smooth as silk and
gliding like Joker downstairs so get 20%
off plus free shipping from your perfect
package 2.0 purchase when you use the
promo code rockstars 20 at manscaped com
so let's move on to the next murder if
that's what we'll call him Arthur
killing his mother penny Fleck he
suffocates her with a pillow in her
hospital bed but notice she's got a
nasal breathing tube plugged into her
notes during this now those tubes
provide a light flow of oxygen they're
not scuba gear
but unless Arthur pinched the tube or
squeezed her throats
neither of what she does in the scene
penny should be getting some oxygen
so while Arthur has been built up to get
revenge against the mother who abused
him there's enough inconsistencies here
to imply that maybe it's just another
thing that he might have imagined but
let's move on to the most violent murder
the film at least my eyes Arthur killing
Randall
now this murder goes down in front of a
witness Gary Arthur stabs Randall in the
neck and I with scissors and then slams
the said repeatedly against the post
spraying himself with blood it's all
very vivid no inconsistencies from what
I can tell but it is worth considering
the context that the scene takes place
in Randall and Gary arrive after two
events that evidence has shown might not
have even happened first Penny's death
for reasons we've talked about but
second Arthur getting invited to appear
on Murray Franklin's show now that phone
call comes in in an interesting way
Arthur climbs into his refrigerator and
locks himself in as one does and all the
while the phone is ringing in the
foreground and the frame cuts to the
phone still ringing the sound effect
uninterrupted but then Arthur walks in
from his bedroom differently dressed to
answer this phone call the Edit here
obscures the timeline of this phone call
it's a bit confusing you could even
argue a version of reality exists in
which Arthur never really made it out of
that fridge but I think it is possible
that Arthur never truly received a phone
call invited him onto Murray's show and
to me that would make sense because
while Murray Franklin is kind of the
[ __ ] to Maki
mentally ill person on light TV he's
less of the late-night provocateur that
David Letterman was in the 80s than the
Johnny Carson style mr. mainstream so
including Randall's death I see
everything that happens in the third act
of Joker through a very skeptical eye
and that includes Arthur's murder of
Marie Franklin while appearing on the
show Arthur confesses to murdering the
men on the train he rages against Murray
in all of society for being what he
calls awful and he shouts one last joke
what do you get when you cross a
mentally ill loner with a society that
abandons him and treats it like trash
Hokulea get you get what you deserve and
bang I think it is important to note
that Arthur's final words to Murray are
a joke because it is a joke that he
finally last genuinely act in the final
scene a joke that he says we wouldn't
get the entire film is structured like a
joke over and over there's a long set up
building up our expectations
- Arthur committed suicide live on TV
something he intended as a punchline to
a knock-knock joke until finally at the
last second this grand joke subverts our
expectations with a different punchline
instead of shooting himself he shoots
Murray it is this punchline - which
Arthur finally enjoys a sincere 40
laughs not a nervous tic or a symptom of
his condition but a true belly laugh and
that laugh is followed by one final kill
that of the psychiatrist which oddly
happens off screen and it comes the most
appropriate and killer why is there so
much blood how did he get out of his
cuffs and why would he violent
incarcerate a killer be left
unsupervised with a psychiatrist yeah
there is definitely enough evidence here
to see Arthur flake not as a murderer
but as a madman who imagines himself as
a murderer or perhaps yeah a murderer
but a killer of other people that we
never see now fantasizing about killing
different people important people and
all of it having a different effect they
had to see in which he is an inspiration
to a lot of horrible things happening in
Gotham society now beyond these that
have mentioned there are even more
subtle moments throughout Joker that are
hinted to be false but I plan to break
down each of those in an upcoming video
a new show that I'm gonna be doing with
Philomena and I'm very very excited
about you're definitely gonna want to
check it out but me time comment down
below with your thoughts on all this
follow me on instagram and twitter at
most in the game and a big thanks to our
patron Taj Jesperson starting from
saying that wrong but you're a hero of
mine thank you all for joining me and
hosting new rock stars videos is the
fantasy of this madman
[Music]